Let us examine what we
learned in this lecture.
We built an expert-trained
model by a physician
that can accurately identify
diabetic patients receiving
low quality care.
We have observed that the out
of sample accuracy of the model
was 78%.
But most importantly, the
model identifies most patients
receiving poor care, which
is the major objective
in the study.
Logistic regression
models provide
probabilities of somebody
receiving poor quality care.
These probabilities can be
used to prioritize patients
for intervention, a particularly
useful outcome from the study.
While the accuracy is
reasonably high, 78%,
it can be, of course,
further improved.
In that respect, I expect that
electronic medical records, not
only claims, could
be used in the future
to enhance the predictive
capability of such models.
So a model like the
one we built can
be used to analyze literally
millions of records.
Whereas a human can only
accurately analyze rather small
amounts of information.
So clearly such a model
allows significantly larger
scalability.
Of course models do not
replace expert judgement.
However, models provide a way
to translate expert judgement
to a reproducible, testable
prediction methodology that
has significantly higher
scalability, as we discussed.
And of course experts can
continuously improve and refine
the model, as we have
seen in this lecture.
Finally, and quite
importantly, models
can integrate assessments
of multiple experts
into one final, unbiased,
and unemotional prediction.
And such methods of combining
assessments and combining
models is a tool
that we will use
later in the class
on multiple occasions
as a way of enhancing and
improving quantitative models.